in this video we're going to think about
function inverses a little bit more or
whether functions are inverses of each
other and specifically we're going to
think about can we tell that by
essentially looking at a few inputs for
the functions and a few outputs
so for example let's say we have f of x
is equal to
x squared plus 3
and let's say that g of x
is
equal to
the square root the principal root of x
minus 3.
pause this video and think about whether
f and g are inverses of each other
all right now one approach is to try out
some values
so for example let me make a little
table here for f so this is x and then
this would be f of x
and then let me do the same thing for g
so we have x
and then we have
g
of x now first let's try a simple value
if we try out the value 1 what is f of 1
what's going to be 1 squared plus 3
that's 1 plus 3 that is 4.
so if g is an inverse of f then if i
input 4 here i should get 1. now that
would prove that they're inverses but if
it is an inverse we should at least be
able to get that so let's see if that's
true
so if we take 4 here 4 minus 3 is 1 the
principal root of that is 1.
so that's looking pretty good let's try
one more value here let's try two
two squared plus three
is seven
now let's try out seven here
seven
minus three is four the principal root
of that is 2.
so so far it is looking pretty good
but then what happens if we try a
negative value pause the video and think
about that
so let's do that
let me put a
let me put a negative 2
right over here now if i have negative 2
squared that's positive 4 plus 3 is 7.
so i have 7 here
but we already know that when we input 7
into g
we don't get negative 2 we get 2. in
fact there's no way to get negative 2
out of this function right over here so
we have just found a case and frankly
any negative number that you try to use
would be a case where you can show that
these are not inverses of each other
not
inverses
so you actually can use specific points
to determine that two functions like
this especially functions that are
defined over really an infinite number
of values these are continuous functions
that using specific points you can show
examples where they are not inverses but
you actually can't use specific points
to prove that they are inverses because
there's an
infinite number of values that you could
input into these functions and there's
no way that you're going to be able to
try out every value for example
if i were to tell you that h of x really
simple functions h of x is equal to 4x
and let's say
that j of x is equal to x over 4.
we know that these are inverses of each
other we'll prove it in other ways in
future videos but you can't try every
single input here and every and look at
every single output and every single
input here and every single output so we
need some other technique other than
just looking at specific values to prove
that two functions are inverses of each
other although you can use specific
values to prove that they are not
inverses of each other